face masks every anywhere so there were
pretty loud cheers from tory back
benches for that it's the end of plan b
which of course uh a hundred or so uh
tory mps
rebelled on uh sajid javid will
inevitably ask whether he's backing the
prime minister to survive to continue
no doubt he will give a pledge of
loyalty but he'll be asked nevertheless
but really this is all about
moving from plan b back to plan a and
susan hopkins and and mr javid will no
doubt be asked whether it is safe to do
so uh mr javid will no doubt be asked um
is this all uh done on public health
grounds or on grounds of party
management by the prime minister as part
of what's been called a operation
we're gonna have to interrupt you there
brother ridley and take yourselves
straight to dining street we'll be
hearing from the health secretary good
afternoon and welcome
today marks the start of the next
chapter in this country's fight against
covid19
a few hours ago the prime minister
announced
thanks to the progress that we've all
made
we will be lifting the plan b measures
and returning to our original plan a
this is a moment that we can all be
proud of
the culmination of a brilliant national
mission
that helped us to withstand the omicron
wave
and restore more freedom to this country
it's a reminder of what this country can
accomplish
when we all work together
we'll shortly be hearing from the chief
medical advisor to the uk health
security agency dr susan hopkins
but before we do
i wanted to talk about how we got to
this important milestone
and what this means for our fight
against this virus
let's start with how we got here
back in july
we made the decision
to take step four of our roadmap
so that we could roll back the
restrictions and move closer to normal
life
this wasn't an easy decision
but taking this step when we did
backed by the warmer weather and the
school holidays
it helped us to enjoy the greatest
possible freedoms for a number of months
as i said when i announced that change
this showed us how we can learn to live
with covid
but i also warned
that a more harmful new variant would
have the potential to set us back
four months later
our scientists
learning from their colleagues in south
africa
were amongst the first in the world to
help identify a new variant omicron
a variant that was capable of spreading
faster than any covert variant that had
come before it
spurred by this new transmissible
variant
case numbers rose to record levels
and incredibly
over a third of the uk's total number of
confirmed covert 19 cases
happened over the last eight weeks
there was a lot we didn't know about
omicron
but we did know
that we were in a stronger position than
the previous winter
thanks to that decision to open up in
the summer
and to the solid defenses that we've
built up over time
so we decided not to return to the
lockdown measures
as many countries in europe have
because i've always been extremely
conscious of the impact that blanket
restrictions can have
for instance on jobs
on education
on mental health
instead
we pursued a different path
one that allowed us to take a balanced
and proportionate approach
we put in place the plan b contingency
measures that were set out in the autumn
and winter plan
these measures
left us with far fewer restrictions than
most in europe
and they bought us valuable time
time that we could use to assess the
omicron variant
and reinforce this country's
pharmaceutical defenses
since we announced plan b
15 million people
have stepped forward to get their
boosters
we have smashed records again and again
including a record
1.06 million uk vaccinations in a single
day
we've also massively expanded our
capacity for testing
and we expect to have some 400 million
lateral flow tests available this month
alone that's quadruple our pre-omicron
plans
on top of this
we secured even more antivirals and
treatments
and deployed them directly
to those people with the highest risk
thanks to this huge collective effort
we're more boosted
than any large country in europe
we've created the largest testing
program of any country in europe
and we've procured more anti-virals than
any country in europe
that's why we are the most open country
in europe and today
we've announced plans to go even further
our plan was to use the time that plan b
gave us
to give ourselves extra power
in our fight against omicron
this plan has worked
and the data shows
that omicron
is in retreat
today's ons data shows a four in
infections
including in older age groups
hospitalizations have also fallen over
the past week and the number of patients
covered patients in intensive care beds
is now at the same level as it was back
in july
i've always said that we would open up
the country as soon as the data supports
it
and earlier today that's why we
announced three important changes as
part of our return to plan a
first
starting immediately
the government is ending the guidance on
working from home
and i know that many people have already
started talking to their employers about
making arrangements
to return safely to work
second
from the start of next thursday
mandatory certification based on
vaccines and tests will end
but of course organizations can still
choose to use the nhs coveted paths
voluntarily
third
also starting next thursday
will no longer legally mandate the
wearing of face masks
but we must suggest
that they are worn in enclosed and
crowded places especially where you come
into contact with people that you don't
normally meet
these changes will take effect sooner
even sooner in classrooms where we will
no longer require face coverings from
tomorrow
and the department of education will
shortly remove the guidance on their use
in communal areas
as well as these changes
we're also exploring what else we can
ease where else we can ease restrictions
we're looking to replace legal
requirements on self-isolation with
guidance and advice
and in the coming days i'll be setting
out our plans to further ease
restrictions on visits to care homes
the steps that we've announced today
represent a major milestone
but it's not the end of the road
and we shouldn't see this as the finish
line
because
we cannot eradicate this virus
and its future variants
instead
we must learn to live with covid in the
same way that we've learned to live with
flu
and we setting out our long-term plan
for living with code 19 this spring
we must stay vigilant
and be mindful
that there could be bumps in the road
ahead
although
we've worked hard to make sure that the
nhs will be ready and resilient
building nightingale surge hubs
and signing new deals with the
independent sector
it is still facing significant pressure
this winter
even before the omicron wave we had a
covered backlog of elective care
and now unfortunately that covered
backlog will be larger still
so we must proceed with caution
a pandemic
is a marathon not a sprint
even on this day of progress i urge
everyone
to think about what they can do
to help keep the virus at bay
whether it's washing your hands
letting in fresh air
or getting tested and self-isolating if
you're positive
but the best step
that we can all take
is to get vaccinated
it was the jabs that have got us this
far and the jabs can keep us here too
i'm so grateful
to all the staff the volunteers the
military everyone that worked on the
rollout program
we asked you
to come forward
and you did
in your millions and it's because of you
that we've been able to take these steps
today
but for as long as there are people who
haven't been protected
we know that our defenses
aren't as strong as they should be
and the nhs will be under more pressure
than it should be
so please
if you haven't heard
your first
second or third jab
it's time to come forward
help us keep this success story going
and protect the incredible progress
that we have all made
now i'd like to hand over to susan who
will talk us through some of the latest
data thank you first slide please
this slide highlights the number of
cases that we've seen testing positive
in the uk and two important points one
is that you can see that in december
january we had a three-fold higher
number of cases detected than we did in
a similar period last year in the middle
of the alpha wave
the most recent seven day average is 93
210 cases per day and that has come down
quite substantially from a peak on the
29th of december at almost 225 000 cases
next slide please
and this is also reflected in our
hospitalization data
here you can see that we are have
reached uh case numbers of less than
twenty thousand uh in in cases in
hospital across the uk
and again that is less than half the
peak that we saw last december january
2020 2021.
it's also important to note that there
are only 703 patients in mechanical
ventilator beds and that's a little
level that is as low as last july when
we also opened up in this country
it's also much much lower than we saw in
the wave in last january
this is reflecting our high levels of
vaccination in the population and also
the reduced severity that we have seen
with omicron
next slide please
and here you show the amazing progress
that we have made with 52 million people
who having received their first dose
more than 48 million people on their
second dose and 36.6
having received their booster our third
dose that's two-thirds of the
eligible population in this country and
we have more to do we really need those
other individuals who have not had their
first second or third dose to come
forward as soon as possible to have the
greatest levels of protection
next slide
please here this shows you the benefits
of protection with vaccination what you
can see on the slide the first graph is
the levels of protection in individuals
who are admitted to the intensive care
unit and if you focus on the red
coloring what you can see in that is
more than half the people that being
admitted to icu over the last seven or
eight months are unvaccinated
and if you also see the smaller
proportions that have had two doses and
a booster in comparison to the general
population and you can see in the
general population only ten percent of
individuals are unvaccinated but those
individuals are disproportionately being
admitted to icu
the greatest thing that you can do to
protect yourself against icu admission
and hospital admission too is get
vaccinated next slide please
and here it shows why we're in such a
good position in this country right now
why we've seen reductions in our
hospitalization compared to where we
could have expected
a month ago where we see reductions in
our case numbers and falling case
numbers in the country this relates to
our booster campaign
and we have now got compared to
comparable countries across
europe and north america the highest
rate of boosters in our population
overall
we can see that other countries are
rapidly trying to
increase their booster campaign
and we also know that this is affecting
their hospitalization rates and cases in
their population
so the strongest defense we have against
the omicron wave that we are now
experiencing and any future waves of
variants that we might experience is
vaccination so i urge everyone to take
up their offer as soon as possible thank
you
thank you very much susan
now we're going to turn to questions and
the first two questions are for members
of the public and i believe the first
one is
christina from berkshire
given the increasing number of
hospitalizations of young children with
covet 19 are there plans to vaccinate
children under 12.
thank you christina for your uh question
that we at at this point first of all
our vaccination program is uh is focused
on the over 12s at the moment and as
you've heard we have had a great success
but you're right to to raise uh under
12s and uh and we take advice uh from
our expert advisors the the jc vi and we
have asked them uh to
to look at this and at this point uh
what they have uh advised us is that we
should uh vaccinate uh under under 12
that are at risk and and that is exactly
what we plan to do and we plan to start
that this month but they are keeping
that under review to see if we should
expand that
more broadly to everyone in that cohort
thank you christina
next i believe it's michelle from
lincolnshire
please can you explain why the
self-isolation period has changed to
five days with negative lateral flow
tests when right from the beginning of
the pandemic it has been advised that if
you have had covid
then you shouldn't do a lateral flow or
pcr test for 90 days as you could have
false results
this question needs to be answered as
people are losing faith in the system
susan would you like to take it on yes
so so what we know is that you can
remain pcr positive for quite some time
which is why we don't advise repeated
pcr tests unless you've got new symptoms
however lateral flow and the evidence
for lateral flow has come hard and fast
over the last six to nine months and
what we recognize now is that once
individuals have finished their
infectious episode those lateral flow
tests become negative and remain
negative and for the vast majority of
people
what we have now advised is that and
looked at very carefully is that the
individuals who have two negative
lateral flows can be released from
isolation early at the earliest that can
be is is after their five and six and
release on day six
and that allows people to get back into
the workplace and to get back out into
the school as well
so it's really an emerging evidence and
changing at the evidence base rather
than any new advice in that way
thank you
thank you susan
next i will turn to
the journalists and the first i have on
my list is hugh pim from bbc news
thank you secretary of state
uh first of all one one for you
how can the prime minister continue to
lead the country when one of his most
senior mps in the commons has called on
him to resign
and one for dr hopkins
cases have risen rapidly fueled by
omicron do you expect them to continue
falling quite quickly
so thank you hugh i was with the prime
minister today in parliament when he he
set out uh our response uh to to covet
and there was a huge amount of support
for for what he set out and anyone could
i think see that whether you're in
parliament or or watching
and uh
and obviously the the what we've seen in
the in the last few weeks and what we've
been seeing whether it's in our
newspapers on the bbc or elsewhere it's
caused a lot of pain and anger and i of
course like anyone else i i absolutely
understand that
and the prime minister has rightly he's
come to parliament he's apologized and
he has uh asked for the time and space
for the investigation that's taking
place to be completed so the facts can
be established and then he will come
back to parliament and answer any
questions and be happily scrutinized on
on those facts once they're established
thank you on case is falling so we've
seen cases fall now for the last two
weeks uh and that is good news and
actually they're starting to fall all
across the country in all regions there
is of course some age differences so
some age groups are seeing plateaus or
some still sight rises and therefore
while we believe that overall we will
continue to see declines in cases that
may plateau at some points as the
infection is in various different
populations
it's very hard to see beyond two to
three weeks and clearly the biggest
change that's going to happen is
people's behavior
and people's behavior and how they react
to the removal of plan b will determine
how fast infection can spread in the
population the biggest response that we
all have as individuals is to take our
personal behavior seriously and that
really is driving towards in vaccination
uptake as well as remembering to wear
face coverings when you're in enclosed
spaces
with people that you don't know
thank you
next i have tom from sky please
thank you
today
what is the public health justification
rending the requirements to self uh to
self isolate if infected and if the
government does bring that forward is it
prepared to do so against the guidance
of the who during a global pandemic
and given the suggestion that today's
announcements have only been made given
the political difficulty the prime
minister finds himself in do you use
health secretary offer him your
unqualified support or are you like
rishi sunak going to reserve judgment
ahead of the great report and can you
hand on heart say that you've never
spent the rules
okay well
let me start and
on that i mean first you asked about the
self-isolation rules ending the
self-isolation rules if you're positive
of course that is still a requirement uh
that it is something that as i've said a
moment ago the prime minister's referred
to today we will review so there's no
decision on that at this point but it is
clear that despite the the changes that
we're announcing today there is still a
very high rate of prevalence some i
think around one in 20 according to the
latest ons
data and it is important currently to to
keep those rules in place we will of
course review them uh i don't want to
presume the outcome of that review but
it is reasonable to think just as
we're living with flu for example we
don't require people to legally
self-isolate but to remain cautious to
be sensible if they're infected we will
eventually have to find a way to live
with kovid in a similar fashion
on your question about the the prime
minister i fully support the prime
minister
and as i said a moment ago it's
important to me into the country that
he's come to the house he's apologized
and uh i think it's right that we're
waiting for the outcome of of the report
and when that is complete this
investigation establishes the facts that
the prime minister will come back and
answer further questions and i think you
asked me about
me and rules whether i have observed the
rules if i heard you correctly and
you know i i can say i've i
with full confidence i've absolutely
observed the covert 19 rules at all
times
and
i would say
you like millions
of people across the country
it hasn't been easy you're like like
millions i my mom lives alone i couldn't
go and see her uh i couldn't go to a
close friend's funeral
and it wasn't easy
but it was the right thing to do as as
millions have done up and down the
country when they were asked to and
it's it's important also that
that if we look at today's announcement
that you know because millions and
millions have observed the rules they've
done the right thing that we can take
the measures that we're taking today and
remove these restrictions on our
freedoms which should always be a last
resort so i'm proud of the british
people and what they've allowed us to
achieve in our fight against this horrid
virus
susan did you want to say anything on
the self-isolation rules as well well i
mean i would just add that for the vast
majority of conditions either
self-isolation as cases or
self-isolationist contacts of cases
isn't a legal requirement but we give
solid public health advice and people
follow that
even now people are as cases
within the rules they are able to take
testing to leave early and as contacts
if you're vaccinated you're able to
leave every day
having done a daily lateral flow test so
i think it is just one element of the
restrictions i think if we removed all
elements on cases and contacts right now
at this moment in the pandemic that
would be different but a legal
requirement is only one component of it
thank you tom i mean it should remain in
place
you know bringing it forward the prime
minister hinted
earlier march yet we still have cases
the highest levels of infections we've
ever seen
well tom just to say that that review is
is something that we will do but at this
point in time
those uh requirements the need to
self-isolate if you're positive remain
very important
may i next turn to emily from itv please
thank you secretary of state um i
wondered whether you are personally
frustrated that you are constantly
having to defend the prime minister's
actions while at the same time having to
deliver very important public health
advice and also uh if i may just to
follow on from tom's question is what
you're saying today that by the end of
march we will effectively be living with
no restrictions in place whatsoever
thank you emily
the
in again when it comes to the the
you know what
has happened in number 10 um
the the the photos and videos and things
that we've all seen and we've all
understandably i think all of us have
been pained by that angered by that it
is right for the prime minister to
respond and he has uh responded in in
parliament and he will come back to
parliament once the investigation is
complete and i think that is the is the
right approach um in terms of the um
what happens at the end of march uh i i
think first of all we can reflect on the
last eight weeks that's that's what it's
been i know it probably feels like
longer with omicron it's been eight
weeks as i said that's accounts for uh a
third of all the covered 19 infections
we've seen thus far throughout this
pandemic and and if we look back at that
i do think we've got all the big
decisions right we didn't get throughout
this pandemic we haven't got every
single decision right all the small ones
but we got the big decisions right and
that's ultimately what matters and
that's why we're able to take these
steps today and be the freest country in
europe now there still are some
requirements restrictions in place such
as the the need to self-isolate if
you're positive there's some travel
requirements still on lfd testing and it
is right that we review those and i will
come back in the spring and set out how
we will live with kovid but the the way
we are going to do this is that we are
going to have to find a way uh to remove
almost all of these restrictions and and
get life completely back to normal but
with one or two really big things that i
think that will be there for a while
that is probably the need to vaccinate i
can't tell you how often that will be
but i think vaccinations will remain
hugely important just as we have to have
annual vaccinations certainly for older
people against flu and i think
antivirals and treatments will continue
to play a big role especially for those
that might be more exposed and i think
testing it it's great where we are today
with testing i think it will improve
over time and these pharmaceutical
defenses of of the the the vaccines uh
antivirals monoclonal antibodies and
testing i think they will be the
cornerstone of our future defenses
thank you emily i'll next uh move to
david please from pa
uh health secretary the latest recorded
daily deaths figure is 359 you're now
lifting restrictions is this the kind of
daily death toll you think the country
has to be comfortable with as part of
the shift to living with kovid
and after the events of the past few
days the prime do you think the prime
minister's living on borrowed time and
will you be throwing your hut into the
ring in the leadership contest again
unto dr hopkins is the uk hsa completely
comfortable with the measures that were
announced today and has any assessment
be made of what they will do to cases uh
removing the legal requirements on face
masks and the end of the work from home
guidance
good
thank you for your question the first on
on the daily uh death toll
it is uh
throughout this pandemic some over 150
000 uh deaths uh that we've seen people
across the country have lost their
friends their their loved ones and of
course
no one wants to see anything uh like
that and it's happened across the world
uh thankfully we're in a place today
because of the vaccines primarily that
that the the the death rate has has
fallen dramatically and as susan had
said earlier and shown with her with the
with the data uh with omicron in
particular the number of people in
intensive care is is uh uh even lower
now than it was um before uh omicron
came along and and that's important uh
but again we can't stress enough how
important it is to get vaccinated
because that's the way uh to to to keep
death slow uh you mentioned uh the
number of uh people dying uh the
the the and you mentioned the latest
number um
the numbers do vary day by day there are
some reporting differences on uh
depending on what day of the week
that is picked but if you look at the
average uh daily uh
death rate the seven day average i think
it's around 200 in in england which is a
lot lot lower than it's been before and
we want it to get lower uh and there's
something else i think is important to
point out about the death rate which
maybe susan might expand on when when
when i've come to her it is uh also with
omicron we know that if we look at
infections of people with covid in
hospital
we estimate around 40 percent of the
people with covid in hospital uh are
there uh not because they've got covid
they happen to have covid so it's a what
you might call an incidental
infection so they're not there being
treated for covid and that's almost
double the percentage that we saw with
delta and that's important because the
deaths that are being reported of uh of
people uh that had that were covered
positive within 28 days of of uh passing
away
that many of those people
would not have necessarily died of covid
and what we're seeing in hospitals uh
that proportion of roughly 40 percent
not being there because of covid is an
indicator of that what susan might
expand on is that the ons has has very
detailed data on that which i think
they'll come out with shortly where they
look at the actual cause of death on
death certificates and i think that will
be important data when it comes uh your
second
question oh yeah you asked about
leadership well look we we have a leader
we have a prime minister the prime
minister is uh is is busy delivering for
this country he's delivered on brexit
he's delivered on jobs he's delivering
on fighting this pandemic and i've got a
job and that's a very important job and
that's uh health and social care my job
is to make sure that health and social
care is the very best it can be in this
great country
susan great so just i'll take it in two
parts so first of all in the deaths
within 28 days we regard this as a
leading indicator and something we
monitor very carefully but as the
secretary of state has said
it does doesn't take into account people
who've died with kovid who've had a
diagnosis and given the very large
number of cases that we've diagnosed in
the last number of weeks we will sadly
see some people particularly the very
elderly who die within 28 days of a case
of covet so we look very carefully at
the ons data and ons data released their
data weekly however in the in the last
two weeks it's always lagged because uh
the death registrations need to come
through
and we will continue to keep a
monitoring on the number of deaths that
we're seeing within 28 days and the
number of deaths that o and s are
reporting that are on the death
certificate so therefore related to the
death in some way
and if we see those diverge we will
discuss it further and highlight the
reasons for that
on the second part which is the
components of face coverings and working
from home so i i think what we've seen
is the case numbers have declined uh
it's people's behavior that are going to
make the difference over the next four
weeks on whether those case numbers
continue to decline stay the same or
rise
clearly when you're working from home
you have less social contact but we're
already seeing some people start to go
back into the office and mix and
socialize more they need to do that
carefully and within the guidelines and
taking care particularly when they're on
public transport in indoor spaces and
crowded places to our face coverings to
test regularly if they're going back out
and meeting people particularly those
who are more vulnerable and finally to
ensure that they've taken up that
vaccination offer because the end of the
day the more people who are vaccinated
the less likely we will see
large transmission especially in those
individuals who've had a booster dose
thank you susan
next uh jane please from the eye
thank you um to the health secretary can
you rule out a return of plan b if
another variant of concern emerges
and also the prime minister said today
that the government had got the big
things on covid right and i think you've
echoed that
including not introducing tougher
measures in england over christmas
in response to omicron but the prime
minister just got lucky didn't he boris
johnson wanted to introduce tougher
measures before christmas but he was
blocked by the cabinet and the tory
party before christmas how can he
portray this as strong leadership when
he was left with no choice
and if i could also ask dr hopkins what
is the scientific evidence and your
assessment for scrapping self-isolation
in march or even earlier as the prime
minister has suggested today thank you
thank you for the question
first of all in in terms of um
looking ahead
as i as i said a a moment ago
this pandemic is still with us it's not
the end of the road there will be bumps
on the road ahead none of us know what
these bombs are going to be there will
be future variants there are many
variants uh between
delta and omicron but many of them they
weren't that dangerous and uh that much
of concern but then suddenly omicron
comes along and and then we all know
what happened so we have to remain
vigilant for uh
against future variants
and
also learn from what we've done and what
we have learned and i think especially
over the last couple of months
is that our pharmaceutical defenses
really do work you know the the vaccines
especially the boosters the the uh the
testing the mass testing uh the uh
and the the focus on antivirals and
other treatments and also how the
british people respond because when we
when omicron came about and we were very
open about it and the risks the british
people responded fantastically in such a
responsible way taking tests if they
were meeting you know perhaps elderly
people or or
going to a high risk place you're
getting vaccinated in their millions the
most boosted country in europe so
this i think these are the kind of
measures as we as we look ahead and then
to your second point uh that i think you
you said something like uh did the the
prime minister just sort of get lucky
of course not the prime minister has
shown leadership uh throughout uh but
when we think about the emergence of
omicron and what happened of course as
ministers we receive lots of advice not
just on on the public health risk which
is hugely important advice
we get advice on
what might be the impact of certain
measures on the economy on on
on education on um other health issues
mental health your cancer outcomes these
are all vitally important and what the
prime minister has to do and only he can
do as the head of the government is to
balance all those up and come to a
judgment and that's exactly what the
prime minister did and and the central
decision uh that that he made which was
to absolutely focus on boosters has been
vindicated and when you look back at
those charts that susan shared earlier
if you look at uh the booster rate in
the uk not just versus europe but even
countries like israel that started
before us when you look at that that is
the main reason we are where we are
today because the the prime minister
made his decisions the country responded
in their millions and it's left us where
we are today opening up the country of
course remaining cautious and vigilant
but we can take the measures that we've
taken today
susan um so i think calling it scrapping
self-isolation is a bit simple uh what
we have done over time is look at the
evidence
we now reduce the isolation period for
people who are cases
from what was 10 days down to
potentially just five days if you have
two negative lateral flow tests so
that's almost half for many people
in addition for those people who are
contacts um if you're vaccinated you can
do daily lfds and not need to
self-isolate already
and so that is the vast majority of the
country as uh you know the vast majority
of the adult population have had two
doses and therefore meet that
for other individuals we still ask them
to self-isolate and we'll continue to
look at that and look at alternatives
and review the scientific evidence
and we will continue to monitor the
impact of this virus in the population
and i do come back to the fact that for
other diseases we recommend to people
how long they isolate for for when
they've got symptoms and we recommend to
contacts how long they isolate for if
they're
if they're a close contact but we also
use other things such as treatments and
prophylaxis to prevent disease and as we
move through this
pandemic we will develop new tools like
we've developed lateral flow to allow us
to change
the approach and to use science to
inform uh government policy
thank you susan
and then finally to
yasmin at the financial times
thank you i just have a couple of
questions for the health secretary given
the ongoing anger over parties of in
downing street and whitehall what's your
response to those watching from home who
would argue that the government's really
lost all credibility when it comes to
leading the nation through these final
stages of the pandemic and secondly just
to follow up on david's question about
impact assessments in prime minister's
questions today labour called on the
government to publish the scientific
evidence supporting the pm's decision to
move to plan a do you plan on doing that
and will you be publishing some form of
impact assessment on the lifting of
restrictions say for example on the
health service and finally are you able
to provide any update as to when the
government will be changing the
definition of fully vaccinated to having
two jobs and one booster
okay
thank you very much uh yasmin
you're you're look you're absolutely
right uh
to to point to the public anger how
pained people have been
through
what they've seen and learned whether
through through
media publications through tv
uh around um
parties and all of that
and
and
you know everyone's been angered by it
yeah i've been angered by it i'm pained
by it you are i'm sure and uh and that
is perfectly understandable and it is it
is right the the the prime minister has
come to parliament he's accepted already
that there's been mistakes
but he has asked for a proper
thorough investigation to be done to
establish the facts
and then he will respond to that he will
properly respond to that to parliament
and to the british people
as he should and as he said he would and
and and that is going to be an important
moment and and the british people once
they've seen the outcome of the
investigation they've heard the prime
minister's response then they can make
an ultimate judgment for themselves as
they should you know it's their country
they vote in a government and decide you
know what should should happen it is
their right that they get the full facts
and decide uh for themselves but i
absolutely uh understand uh the anger
and the pain and in terms of um
the second part of your question the the
evidence around the decisions we've made
uh that uh you know throughout the
pandemic uh we've been sharing uh
evidence the through parliament and and
through on the website for example of
the ukhsa and in other ways and we will
continue to do that be open and
transparent and there'll be many impact
assessments that we've published
with respect to the pandemic and we
always keep that in review and we're as
transparent
as
as we can be that's that's really very
important and having you know sessions
like this where whether it's members of
the public or people like yourself
yasmin can ask us questions anything you
want is part of that uh transparency and
then in it it answers your final part of
your question uh we are looking at the
definition of uh fully vaccinated uh it
is
something that if we just look at what
we've learned in the last few weeks we
know that two vaccines are not enough
against uh omicron they're nowhere near
enough uh they just don't work in terms
of protecting certainly from
hospitalization but we know that three
vaccines uh that uh they can give you i
think is it susan 88 protection 88
protection against hospitalization and
and so they work and that's why we are
where we are today that's why we've made
uh this progress and it's right that we
keep reviewing and updating uh the
definition of fully vaccination but
we've got to think about how that would
work in practical terms so we are
looking at that and if i make since
the final question it allows me just to
finally say please to anyone listening
if you're eligible and you're not
boosted yet please please do come
forward and help yourself your loved
ones and most of all help our great
country thank you
thank you all very much
and so the latest darning street news
conference uh today's of course hosted
by the health secretary and uh susan
hawkins from the uk health security
agent say well that now comes to a close
uh certainly something about a history
lesson from the health secretary at the
very beginning explaining why in his
mind uh we are where we are today but we
did have confirmed uh that we will by
thursday the 27th of january moved fully
back to plan at the end of the working
from home guidance face mask those
mandatory covered passes for certain
venues however uh sajid javid making
clear that whilst in his view today was
a major milestone it's not quite the end
of the road yet let's bring